yeah yeah well I don't know I mean look
it's funny that when you see pictures of
Trump he's eating Kentucky Fried Chicken
Kentucky Fried Chicken private jet
hilarious he really loves that stuff
loves it really fucking loves fast food
like when he got all those athletes when
they came to visit him when the
government was shut down and brought him
off fast food he didn't understand that
look what the fuck I know this shit and
then he had another team showed up
months later and he broke up as food
again the government was hope just
imagine the fucking you're going to see
the President of the United States and
you're a professional athlete Yeah right
your body literally is a temple and
major college athletes but listen let's
be real about that huh Ashley should get
fucking paid praise that's the biggest
robbery and all of athletics college
sports oh my god chance to get into the
NBA in the NFL but you're making
billions on these kids fucking billions
don't get my sweatshirt money $20 I'm
telling you man this guy in terms of
like material current and future it's
almost like we glutton doubt it's almost
like Trump was ice cream like when he
was in office he was so good for comedy
that it was like there are so many Trump
jokes right now everyone's like no I
need something else I can't have ice
cream these are one more bite yeah ice
cream he's gonna come chuck it out of
your throat it's really true it's so
he's so fucking eccentric like good or
bad just look at him as a human it's
such a rare yeah you know I mean you've
seen it with the with the hair and the
fucking constant golfing even though
he's fuckin Obama golfing and he's gone
he doesn't even try to pretend these men
a hypocrite no not at all
he's just everything he's just the the
fat American on a jet ski just letting
it rip if you know it's also hilarious
is good I think this is a real thing
Trump derangement syndrome I think it's
real you mean people that are obsessed
with him they're obsessed with you know
this is the thing that's gonna get him
he'll be out of office in three weeks
instead of like looking at it
look this is the argument for garlic
Michael Mouse that he's an objective
analyst stepping back looking at this
uh-huh he doesn't here's and have a
vested interest in this guy winning or
that Cayenne and winning he's just going
what is this
right sitting back and watching yeah
this is if I'm going to take that
position not emotionally involved some
people get so emotionally involved they
can't sleep they start crying and they
think it's the end of the world okay the
world is exactly the same we just have a
different figurehead and I think it
would present challenges that will make
us more understanding of each other I do
that's what I really think I think
there's there's good and bad about every
situation but with the pro I see is
communication if we're just honest with
the way we communicate I think people on
the right and people on the left they
share a lot in common there's a lot a
lot that they share rather than what
they don't share in common yeah you know
the only thing they don't share is what
they're watching right and it's also the
vibe you get yeah like there's the vibe
from these whatever whether it's CNN
whatever show you're into MSNBC Fox News
they all give out a vibe yeah and that
vibe is you know we are right here's
what's going on here's why that's a
problem right you know and everyone has
a different problem and everyone thinks
they're right right and you have so you
have different things you some of them
have like Eagles and flags and
your fucking neighborhood let them move
into your fucking neighborhood rachel
maddow
trucks and hats and guns and so that
comes your team that becomes your club
that's what it is it's the team thing
most of it and and the the unfortunate
part is both are saying are spending so
much time rather than thinking about
yeah this is the problem that we have to
deal with they're spending all their
time thinking those other people are
assholes
right exactly it's being it's the the
venomous attacks against fellow
Americans because they have a slightly
different view about health care that
part is the the derangement of the
culture right now